okay so working on the inverse spiral
i'm going to give this tilt
that's the opening this is the hole this
is the hole right here
okay that's the in space
so i create that and there it is
now when i use the inward spiral in this
training drill
i don't want to use my arms
i leave it where it is and hit like it's
simply going to go like this
there's my body creates the opening
you have to watch two things one
is that you create the so-called opening
with your external yin movement of your
wrist
you see unto
once you feel you'll that you got him oh
okay now like that feels pushable
you start to push out with your hand
you'll stop the spiral or you find
oh he's going oh keep going
and you extend just keep the pattern
see it stays here
don't chase him harder
then you always get to make it smaller
and more relaxed without losing anything
okay okay so with my body
i have to let him fall this way
so i can't go like this
he's gonna fall like that
so my body i let his energy pass that's
where he
falls
i can't bring him this way that's not
what's happening
he needs to come this side forward
so i have to let that side of his body
go back
[Music]
you're going like this because you're
pushing
because he's triggering he's pushing a
meal plus when you
push a little push on you it's not push
on me i disappear
push on me i disappear push on me
that's not what we're doing okay it's
here's the conflict
i am producing the conflict as much as
he is
okay so i have the power to
reconcile the conflict
push
push i
i deconstruct that conflict
by not participating in it okay
so let's go back a step and that will
give you
the tsuki the hole inside
his kazushi pod right here right here
see right there because that is where
the umiyashi the
miyasi is made possible if there is no
hope
if all you have is i'm pushing him over
when you cannot enter because he has
young energy and that's why you have to
do arm grappling
okay so let's go back a step in the
inward spiral
and deconstruct it and i should get
the kazushi powder okay so i
i need him to get in this front amber
kazushi pattern
so that means his head is coming this
way and his hips gonna go that way
the head goes this way hip goes that way
so i can't do that when i leave my body
here
so this side has to yield boom
you see
this side can't come forward this side
goes back
that's where i put myself into the hole
that's right you're gonna use your arm
to help us
okay let's see if we should find that
whole day
okay so this reconciliation of the
conflict
is is your uh jiu jitsu
that that has to be there i have to
reconcile the conflict okay
but it's gonna continue so you're gonna
you are going to feel and you go
you're going to do it again he's pushing
on me so there's two
main two other main pushing points
that the unenlightened mind
pushes back off so this this is one okay
then but let's say i get
here now this is the other one right
there you want to do it on the up
okay and then the third one is when you
turn over
and you're going to do it on the out but
you're supposed to reconcile
those two contention points too just
like this one boom
you're going to feel it and you're going
to reconcile you're going to go around
the energy
and emotionally you're going to let go
let go of it
and we're back to the other drill
it looks like i'm pushing him but you're
gonna see this is pushing you see
that's that second push so i do the
first one the second push
then i'll do the third push push you see
and it looks like i'm able to do it but
this is strong man aikido big man aikido
which means not aikido
okay i'll have the first contention
point breakfast hall reconcile reconcile
it's not
[Music]
so because i never push on him
then you can do these magic tricks
there's no way i can push these guys so
stand up
you see holy okay you're gonna
i cannot push on these people okay so
he he's gonna grab him and come around
and this is like a magic trick are you
good right get sit down
okay this is like imagine holy i
can't do that but i have to reconcile
do you see
so if i
this is stupid okay so what i have to do
is i gotta let him come past here i'm
gonna get out of the way
so i get out of the way and then don't
push on me
okay do you get that so um
it's not it's not about becoming
powerful
it's about becoming skilled at
non-contestation
okay that's that's the thing that's what
we're trying to do
okay okay so anything that i'm
contesting i would have to overpower
which is why when you add two people you
can't do the technique but if you were
non-contesting
it i'm not in the contest so it doesn't
matter how many people you are okay
but when you're trying to do ikyo
anything that i'm
pushing is going to stop the idi miyashi
is there's no there's no hole for me to
step in okay so i even though it looks
like i oh i got it i got it i
would not be able to do this you see
which is why
most people prioritize the wrist so
you're gonna push
push push push and this thing's in the
way so you get out of the way oh there's
my hope
do you see but this is not marshall
that is not mechanically sound so i have
to
get out of the way so that i can walk i
can walk easy go around that energy
so i'm going to go around the grip not
clear the grip
okay so i'm going to go around the grip
not there
this this thing i'm going to go around
the grip
so i have to quit pushing him
oh not not there i'll have to go around
the grip
so we're not going to clear the grip
with the other hand we're just going to
go around the grip
okay let's try it
okay so just as i have a contention
and then i'm gonna uh do the suki i see
there's no weight on me i can stand you
see that there's no weight because
i got inside the tsuki okay so the same
thing happens here
uh when i go here i'm not going to push
on him
i'm going to get inside this sticky over
here see
inside there
so i reconcile the first contention
point bob
reconcile the second one reconcile the
third one
and then you're gonna want to do that do
you see but you want to get in this hole
over here
so i get in this hole by stepping into
it and then
his arm is easy to do you see
don't use the arm don't use the arm to
do it
don't go like this
you step inside the city and you're just
inside the suki it's easy
you see
it's like oh there's a little push but
not if i come over here
you see and then i find the arm okay so
it's how you step it's not what you do
with the arm
boom i'm inside and on there
okay so find that second tsuki
holy so if i add a ten mate you see he's
flying into that side right he was
coming this way
he's pushing it right up boom you're
going to hit him on that side you get it
so i am going to hit him and there
there's no
oh i can kick because he he's not
pushing on me
okay so we're gonna do those two
attempts
okay let's go now we go to the technique
but it's all the same
just keep the order but my wrist my
other hand
bone is going to find here but not
do this i'm not that's not how i'm
clearing it i'm going around his energy
around again
so
this is something entirely different
now